قال المتحدث باسمي لجنه المعلمين
السودانيين سامي الباقر للجزيره ان اللجنه
نفذت اضرابا في عدد من ولايات السودان
للمطالبه بتحسين الاجور واضاف المتحدث
باسمي لجنه المعلمين انا الاضراب شامله
المدارس في ولايات الجزيره وصنار
والشماليه والبحر الاحمر انه حقق نجحا
بنسبه
99% كما اكد ان الاضراب في العاصمه
الخرطوم يمضي بشكل ناجح وانه سيستمر لمده
اسبوع كمله لوزاره لتنفيذ مطالب المعلمين
وكان اساتذه جامعات في السودان ايضا نفذوا
وقفه احتجاجيه امام مجلس الوزراء وسط
الخرطوم وقال مراسل الجزيره ان الاساتذه
المشاركين في الاحتجاج سلموا مذكره الى
مجلس الوزراء تتضمن عددا من المطالب
ابرزها تحسين اجور اساتذه الجامعات وشروط
الخدمه وكانت الجامعات السودانيه شهدت
احتجاجات لاساتذه الجامعات في الفتره
الماضيه ادت الى شل العمل في عدد من
الجامعه
وينضم الان الينا مراسلنا الطاهر المرضي
من الخرطوم اذا اييه قطاع التعليم سواء
على مستوى المدارس او مستوى الجامعات
يعاني ازمه وغضب شديد بين صفوف السادسه
بانه في سوره
المطالب وايضا النجاح الذي قال رئيس لجنه
المعلمين انه حقق 99% في عدد من الولايات
نعم هذا الاحتجاج او ما وصفت منه
بالغضب تبين في واقع الحال خاصه اليوم هو
اول يوم
لاستئناف الدراسه بعد عطله
في
الاسابيع الماضيه هذه اليوم نفذ او نفذت
لجنه
الاضراب المعلمين نفذت هذا الاضراب بنسبه
كبيره نحن نحددكم الان من احدى المدارس في
الخرطوم كما تشاهدون المدرسه مغلقه تماما
وخاليه من التلاميذ وكذلك الا من بعض
المعلمين الذين جاءوا همم فقط لاشياء
تخصهم في هذه المدرسه لهم مطالب محدده
تحدثت عنها لجنه المعلمين هذه المطالب
تتحدث بان تطالب الدوله برفع همم نسبه
التمويل
الميزانيه للتعليم بنسبه 20% وكذلك الطالب
بالحد الادنى للاجور خاصه وهم يرون ان
الحد الادنى من الاجور الذي يبلغ فقط 20
دولار هذا مجحف في حق المعلم وكذلك
بالنسبه للبيئه التعليميه ولذلك هم
يطالبون الان بان يرتفع هذا الحد الى نسبه
تتوافق مع الاوضاع المعيشيه خاصه الظروف
الاقتصاديه الان كما انهم يتحدثها ايضا عن
بيئه المدرسه ويتحدثون عن مطالب كثيره
هناك كانت تواصل من همم
الدوله او من الحكومه همم في همم تحقيق
هذه المطالب وانهم توافقوا معهم على عدد
من المطالب ولكن حتى الان هم يرون على اذا
لم يتم تنفيذ هذه المطالب من الصعب ان
يقوم بفتح المدارس واستئناف الدراسه معنا
الان همم نحن في هذه مدرسه الاستاذ فوزي
مدير مدرسه همم الرياض حدثنا عن مطالبكم
الرئيسيه في هذا الليره بسم الله بسم الله
الرحمن الرحيم همم مطالب المعلمين محدده
واا
منصفه بالنسبه لينا اذا عدونا 69 او على
الاقل تقدير لو قعدوا معنا عشان نقدر نصل
لحل وسط عشان نحل المشكله بتاعه انه في
طلبه بيمشوا المدارس اللي هم في المدارس
الخاصه وعندنا طلب المساكين بتاع
الطالبنا انه تحقيق الحد الادنى من الاجور
اللي هي 69 69,000
ده الحد الادنى بعدك بتدرج حسب كله معلم
همم بياخذ كده
هيطلع له كده وبعد كده لحد الان هو 69 اه
1,000 جنيه ايه ده المعلم اللي تكون
المسافه قريبه انت انا باقدر بيتي هذه
الخاص من مصادر ثانيه عشان اقدر اكمل 69
ديه الان يعني ما هو واقع التعليمه الان
بالنسبه اه واقع المعلم في الوضع الحالي
والله واقع المعلم واقع مزري جدا
المعلم يعيش حياه شديده لولا الحياه
والخجل والله كنا هنشوف بلاوي بالنسبه
للوضع بتاع المعلم انا بضرب لي معلمه
الليله انا كمدير المدرسه بيقول لها
استاذه انا لو جئتك للمدرسه بتقدر تديني
حق الرجعه عشان ارجع
ما بقدر يوفر لك لانه انا بعيش نفس الوضع
بتاع المعلم ده ايضا معنا الاستاذ استاذ
علي حسين عبد الرحيم المرحله الثانويه
انتم اليوم في ياتي مدرسه مدرسه الخرطوم
الاهليه شيخ الاهليه
فعلا الاضراب لمده اسبوع الاضراب مفتوح
والله يا اخي ما تخليني الحكومه تحل
المشكله اصلا همم
شهرين وزياده يعني احنا قدمنا ملف من همم
16 اكتوبر الملف يحتوي على مجموعه من
المطالب يعني همم
حصل بيها قرارات وافترض انه الحكومه كانت
تنفذه معنا نفذتها بس حاليا همم بعد تم
ال- همم
اللقاء مع مجلس السياده همم وزير الماليه
تمبل ال- ال- ال- همم الاغرار بانهم
حينفزوا الحاجات اصلا هي كانت مفروض تنفذ
يعني نحن مطالبين بانه لحد الادنى يكون 69
نحن مرتباتنا ضعيفه لابعد الحدود يعني نحن
هسه استاذ في الدرجه الاولى بياخذ 114
فالليل انا باخذ الوجبه 7,000 جنيه و700
جنيه في الشهر
فده همم العلاوه بتاعه الطفل 100 جنيه
العلاوه بتاعه الزوجه 100 جنيه فده كلام
يعني ما في ما في زول في الدوله بياخذ
الكلام ده نحن محتاجين لانه التعليم محتاج
عشان المعلم ده يقدر يؤدي الاداء المطلوب
منه لا بد منه همم
الاستاذ الواحد لو جاء المدرسه ما يقدر
يمشي المعلمين ده اللي بيشتغلوا في مدارس
خاصه عشان يجيبوا قروش يجيبها المدارس
الحكوميه يبقى دي مشكله كبيره يعني حتى
العمل الخاص اللي بيشتغلوا ده المدرسه
يوم الخميس
تلك المطالب
شكرا جزيلا لك الطاهر المرضي